rod knows how to make money he has built
two remarkably successful companies blue
and company which is an accounting firm
you may have used I commend it to you if
you hadn't and Ronald blue and company
which is a whelp advisory firm not only
one but the fourth largest in in America
his alma mater Indiana University
Kelly School Business School named Ron
entrepreneur of the year for his great
success building those companies he
prefers a different award from IU and
that's what those Hoosiers wouldn't win
another national championship but he did
accept the plaque in addition knowing
how to make money Ron knows how to give
money away his founder of the National
Christian Foundation which has helped
high-net-worth and other Christians and
contribute what is now 5 billion dollars
worth of assets in the National
Christian foundation quickly making it
one of the largest foundations in the
world with the largest percentage of
outlays so this isn't just storing up
treasure it's it's moving it out
aggressively Ronald blue and company
financial advisors help their clients
give enough money every year that it's
the equivalent of the assets of a local
office so in effect working against
their assets under management motivation
they're helping clients give because
that's what faithfulness looks like
against their seemingly self-interest
but instead they continue to grow just
as their clients continue to be generous
but finally and the reason here this
morning is because not only does he know
how to make money and give it away and
help others give it away but he knows
how to teach it
he's written 20 books he has formed a
nonprofit organization called kingdom
advisors which trains thousands of
financial professionals every year to be
more faithful stewards and to help their
clients be the same and he's now just
stood up the Ron blue Institute in
Wesley University which is aimed out
across the CCC u world to try and help
you teach your students
more persuasively what the Bible has to
say about money so for all those reasons
I'm so grateful to introduce you to my
friend Ron blue Thank You Jay it's
exactly the way I wrote it
though I so appreciate Dave what you've
done in helping to bring this together
and working with Nita in the event
coordination and knowing a little bit
about what that means I am so
appreciative of the work that you do
Anita and I wrote to Anita and said
what's my job and she said well you're
the principal speaker on Saturday
morning so I'm a numbers guy and I went
looked up the word principal that's
what's left when all the interest is
gone
so I know what my job is and I can
deliver with that but I do appreciate
being here and in thinking about kind of
what to talk about
you know you always think of who your
audience is and to some extent I was
intimidated by the fact of being in
front of academics for a lot of reasons
I'm not an academic I'm much more of an
experiential person and I did get a
doctorate degree from Indiana Wesleyan
honorary but so you can call me doctor
blue I'm okay with that
they said that you spent 50 years
learning enough to be a doctorate so but
thinking about what could I share with
you I want to do there's really three
things there's kind of three segments to
what I want to talk about the first
segment is a little bit of my testimony
where I've come from so you can see the
experience that I've had and the second
then is just what have I learned and I
can't obviously in 30 minutes tell you
everything I've learned but I can get
some highlights and then the third is
where am I going and where would I'd
like to see you all go given the first
two and I want to begin with when I was
asked to speak in a conference subject
was poverty and incidentally I went
through the DVDs from the Acton
Institute on poverty and I think you're
going to hear about those but they were
phenomenal just well done and really
really good stuff but I don't know a lot
about poverty I work with a lot of
wealthy people and always have I did
make eleven trips to Africa in the early
80s and on one of those trips the people
that I was with we were about four hours
outside of Nairobi and we were visiting
with a pastor there was only eight of us
on this trip and we were visiting with a
pastor we were sitting on a hill looking
down at his mud hut and that's roof
and talking to him about that area of
the world and I asked the question I
said pastor what's the greatest barrier
to the spread of the gospel in this part
of the world
now I expected it to be communication or
money or transportation or tribalism or
something like that that would have been
the greatest barrier to the spread of
the gospel but he said something that
changed my thinking and has been a part
of my thinking for almost 40 years now
and what he said was the greatest
barrier to the spread of the gospel and
this part of the world is materialism
now I'm sitting here looking at a mud
hut one-room mud hut
five children four hours outside of
Nairobi and he said it's materialism and
materialism is defined as desire for
wealth and material possessions with
little interest in ethical or spiritual
matters that's there's dictionary
definition of materialism so I said well
pastor I don't understand and he said
well if a man has mud hut he wants a
stone hut if he has it that's roof he
wants a metal roof we've got one acre he
wants two acres he got one cow he wants
two cows and it immediately I got it and
it really has helped me in working with
the wealthy and working in America
because materialism or consumerism is
not a function of amount of wealth it's
a disease of the heart in a contrast to
that just a few years ago I was meeting
with a man who disclosed publicly that
he was worth 6 billion dollars he had no
debt on anything and six billion dollars
and we were having conversation great
conversation I found out later that when
the market crashed in 2008 his net worth
went from 6 billion to 4 billion still
you could probably live on that for a
while and he had given his wife a
million dollars a year to give away and
he took her back because he was like
this and the thing that
impresses me about money and money
management is that it is two things
number one it's a revealer of the heart
and it's an entry into the heart and
scriptures are clear on that
if you if I and I've seen so many
checkbooks and tax returns and
investment portfolios and I say to
people you know if you give me your tax
returns your checkbook and and credit
statements and so forth I can pretty
well write the story of your life and I
certainly can see what your goals are
your values are your priorities are
because your checkbook reveals it and
money and money management is the only
area of the Christian life that you
can't fake you know I can pray I can
share Christ I can act like I'm getting
along with my wife but money we have a
recorded we have it recorded and all
money decisions are symptomatic of
spiritual condition they are no
exception and if you believe that God
owns it all as I do then every financial
decision that you make is a record of
your stewardship now money and money
management I want to be clear on
something I am NOT talking about
stewardship I'm talking about a small
subset of stewardship stewardship is a
much bigger idea its life stewardship
time talent treasure relationships truth
everything I've been given I am a
steward over but there's a small element
of it it riches financial stewardship
and financial stewardship is how do you
handle money how do you what do you
think about money and how do you handle
money just to go back a little bit Jay
gave you a bit of my testimony I started
with peat Marwick Mitchell in New York
City Dallas in San Francisco in 1967 8 &
9 and then went back to Indianapolis
started a CPA firm Jay told you about
that and midway through 1972 my wife
almost died she committed her life to
Christ kind of as that was the initiator
I threatened her with divorce because it
was a threat to my goal of success but
in 1974 after I
watched her live out true Christianity
for two years I accepted Christ on my
way to play golf in 1974 and I shot a 36
on the front side and I thought boy if
I'd known this I'd become a Christian a
long time ago but in 1974 when I
committed my life to Christ that began
to change everything in three years
later left the CPA firm joined a
subsidiary Campus Crusade worked in
evangelism in Africa traveling out of
the US and then in 1979 through the
influence of dr. Howard Hendricks at
Dallas seminary who asked me to take a
look at his finances I started this
company actually company it was me to
help Christians plan to manage their
money so they'd have more money to give
away the first client that I had I was
able to help develop a plan for him he
was a physician
it was making eighty five thousand
dollars a year and he wanted to give a
million dollars to Campus Crusade and
when I did a plan he could do it without
going to all the mechanics he had a lot
more property what he thought he had
he'd never really valued it we started
giving away his property lowered his
taxes increased his cash flow more money
to give away lowered his taxes and it
became a circular thing and I became
kind of a model that we used for
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
clients over time that company grew I
wrote some books I did a lot of radio
television type stuff and in 1990 I had
a vision that God would use her on a
balloon company to fund a billion
dollars a year you know and today that's
happening now I got to tell you that I
left in 2003 the firm and they're doing
a lot better since I left I left blue
and company in 1977 they're doing a lot
better since I left so I'm just
resigning from Kingdom Advisors because
I need to help Larry Burkett challenge
me in 2003 to work with other advisors
and teaching them how to integrate
biblical wisdom into their advice and
counsel which I started with 16 advisors
and today we've got 1,500 advisors
around the country
that are committed to bringing biblical
wisdom into their advice and counsel you
know we're sure a little bit more about
that in just a bit and then the Rambla
Institute came about because of Indiana
Wesleyan asking me if I would assign my
intellectual property to them and then
they would take it distribute it and so
forth and my can my condition was
anything we do at Indiana Wesleyan has
to be made available to the rest of the
body of Christ the other Christian
colleges and universities so it's not a
product to be contained but it's a
product to be distributed and God has
honored that let me let me just switch
that a little bit of my testimony if I
have time I'll tell you the story of the
founding of n CF which J mentioned just
because it brings things together so if
I don't forget I'll share it at the end
and it's easy to forget you know dr.
Einstein was on a train one time and the
conductor came down the aisle and it was
looking for tickets and he's checked
every place he couldn't find his ticket
and the conductor he said doctor I say I
knew who you are I don't have any
problem with that and he went on down
collecting tickets and came back and dr.
Einstein was on the the ground searching
for this ticket and the conductor said
doctor I saying I know who you are
you don't have to have a ticket and dr.
Einstein said you know I know that you
know who I am and I know who I am I just
don't know where I'm going I'm 71 I had
open-heart surgery a year ago and doing
great I feel like I'm about 50 but I do
tend to forget where I'm going also
that's kind of ties those last two
thoughts together so what have I learned
well first of all that fear confusion
and doubt are the things that just drive
everybody and they're just prevalent
everyplace everybody wants to know
what's the answer
the great fear fear of the economy fear
of a lot of things and there's a lot of
confusion you know you can't watch
television without seeing financial
services ads so the work that I feel
that I work in I see all these ads about
financial independence retirement
security pleasure
etc etc so we have a world that is
sending us a message that really lends
itself to fear and confusion and
certainly doubts the other thing that I
know is that generally speaking people
are trying to answer three questions
question number one is will I ever have
enough question number two is if I do
have enough will it continue to be
enough and question number three is by
the way how much is enough how do I
figure that out those are legitimate
questions and almost anybody is trying
to answer those three questions every
one of us have those three questions
additionally there are basically three
goals that drive people financial goals
one is success I'm not using these in
priority order but success drives people
significance drives people and security
drives people so people are trying to
answer those three questions and meet
one or more of those other three goals
which are the drivers Romans 12:2 which
i think is there we go says and do not
be conformed to this world but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
so that you may prove be able to prove
what the will of God is that which is
good acceptable and perfect and here's
the point what I see is that basically
Christians have bought into the world
system when it comes to money they have
conformed themselves to the world system
there's a lot of good in the world
system but they've conformed to it and
what we really need is transformation
transformation of thinking that's why
educators are so critical to what I'm
going to propose in terms of the
direction that we go because if you
don't have transform thinking you're not
going to change anything
your actions are going to indicate what
you really believe and you will stay
conformed to the world I deal with
financial
professionals now and the reality is
that they bought into the world system
too and I've talked to thousands of
financial advisors and here's the
Christian financial adviser thinks this
way
I'm moral I operate with integrity I've
I don't sell my clients something that
is bad therefore I am a Christian
financial advisor wrong because they are
still conformed to the world system when
it comes to how they plan to manage
their finances the beginning point is
what does God's Word have to say and
then if you can determine that then out
of that comes the decisions when I
started
Ronald Lewin company I was really
heavily under the influence of Larry
Burkett I think Larry Burkett
legitimatize biblical principles of
finance and a bunch of us came along
later and did something with that but
Larry was the one that really
legitimatize dit and I happen to have a
background in finance and accounting and
so I went that direction Howard Dayton
went to church direction and others have
gone different directions but the
reality is if it doesn't begin in God's
Word then how do you know you're making
the right decisions I want to share a
story with you about Sherlock Holmes
Sherlock Holmes and dr. Watson went on a
camping trip and after a good meal and a
bottle of wine they laid down for the
night and went to sleep some hours later
Holmes woke up notes his faithful friend
and said Watson I want you to look up at
the sky and tell me what you see Watson
said well I see millions and millions of
stars Sherlock said as a detective and
what does that tell you after a minute
or so of pondering Watson said well
astronomically it tells me that there
are millions of galaxies and potentially
billions of planets
astrologically I observed that Saturn is
in Leo hora logically I deduced that the
time is approximately a quarter past
3:00 in the morning
theologically I can see that God is
all-powerful and that we are small and
insignificant meteorological e I suspect
we'll have a beautiful day today
what does it tell you Holmes Holmes was
silent for about 30 seconds and he said
Watson you idiot
someone has stolen our tent yeah there's
a point to that and the point to it is
this it all depends on your perspective
so if you don't have the right
perspective you're not likely to get to
the right conclusion and I want to share
a couple of perspectives with you
first one is there's a picture of Judy
and I 1965 when we got married that was
our first home 28 feet long 8 feet wide
and 6 feet tall you could sit on the pot
cook dinner and do the ironing without
moving you could it was pretty small we
didn't decide have to decide where we're
going on vacation is we're just going
home one of our parents to get some food
we lived there for a while and then
there was a result to our marriage five
children we had three girls I became a
Christian and we had two boys that's
just that's a fact that's not
necessarily mean anything but it's a
fact but and here's the problem
five multiplies so we've now got when we
get together there's 25 of us this is
our family vacation I think last summer
the summer before five children five
in-laws 13 grandchildren and you know
what nobody has written the book on
raising or parenting adult children amen
anybody that's got adult children knows
what I'm talking about is that's the
most difficult time of being a parent is
when they start parenting their children
and you just can watch they really don't
want your advice you may want your money
but they don't want your advice well
here's the paradox the more you have the
more choices you have which results in
greater confusion and complexity to life
in other words the more you have the
less real freedom you have
because you're having to make more
choices and you've got more alternatives
therefore it becomes a bigger burden
that's not wrong this is just a fact and
the reason that I stay there a lot is
because the American Dream is that if I
have more I'll have enough and I'll have
real freedom and peace of mind and they
reality is no you don't I've worked with
enough people that I know that I've
worked with billionaires and I have
never yet talked to a billionaire who
felt wealthy intellectually they might
know that they're wealthy but but wealth
and security or wealth is not a feeling
but ansel independence is not a feeling
so to understand this is a perspective
now that's also a biblical perspective
so if I understand that that's going to
change the way that I think and
therefore is going to change the way
that I behaved so that's one perspective
that I think is important what I've
learned the paradox of prosperity it's
not about having more ever ever ever
we know that biblically but I can tell
you that also experienced Lee the second
perspective well this is a quote by John
Steinbeck and a letter to Adlai
Stevenson and he said if I wanted to
destroy a nation I would give it too
much and I would have an honest and he's
miserable greedy and SEC tying in to the
paradox of prosperity that was written
in November of 1959 he said what have we
seen since November of 1959 we've seen
the greatest one run-up and wealth that
the world has ever known and where are
we miserable greedy and sick in terms of
a nation so that's one perspective
here's another one this is my year of
birth 1942 was right after Pearl Harbor
and the beginnings of World War two ten
years later when I was 10 I was in the
third grade in Lafayette Indiana this
was during the Korean War the Cold War
the Berlin wall was up bomb shelters
were best shelters this was a picture
out of the Detroit paper in 1952 of
children in a bomb shelter
I remember that those of you that live
in the fifties didn't feel real secure
because of the Cold War and because of
the threat of nuclear war
in 1962 and I was a student at Indiana
University age 20 is when the key to
Khrushchev banged a shoe at the UN and
threatened and says we will bury you
this was the Cold War was hot bet no
more we were in a recession we had the
Cuban Missile Crisis which prompted
Khrushchev's remarks ten years later I
was a CPA in Indianapolis running a CPA
firm was not a believer but that's the
year of the oil embargo anybody here
remember the oil embargo oh yeah this is
an old audience that's great we're
speaking the same language
there was wage price controls Watergate
and the prime hit 10% for the first time
in 1972 but I tell you how this all came
about is that in the early 90s we were
we were entering the last decade of the
millennium and there was a lot of
Millennium talk and I did a lot of radio
stuff in the early 90s and everybody
wanted to know what's going to happen
and so when I I didn't know what was
going to happen anymore than anybody
else knew what was going to happen but I
decided to go back and look at in ten
year increments my life and where were
we and what was I doing and what was
going on so this is the result of that
and when I was 30 these were the things
going on when I was 40 I now had a
finance planning firm lived in Atlanta
this was the start of Ronald balloon
company that's when the prime lending
rate hit 21 percent mortgage rates for
fourteen percent if you remember we had
double-digit inflation gold had eight
hundred an ounce bunker hunt was trying
to control the silver market when it hit
$50 an ounce we had an oil crisis and we
had an inflation mindset that most
people thought we would never break
remember that we have seen the end of a
fixed rate mortgage that was it we have
seen the end there is no way that we'll
ever have a fixed rate mortgage again
and of course what our mortgage rates
today in 1992 when I was 50 Bill Clinton
was elected president we had trade
deficit a budget deficit war in the
Middle East recession political
uncertainty Al Gore hadn't yet invented
the internet and y2k had not yet shown
up but this was the situation in 1992
now when we look back
we know historically that that was the
beginning of the greatest run-up of
wealth during these last 6070 years we
didn't know about the internet we didn't
know about cell phones etc etc 10 years
later when I was 60 was right after 9/11
we were in the midst of war on terrorism
we had corporate fraud at the time in
Iran and and others personal debt was an
all-time high stock market had gone down
dramatically and interest rates have
gone down in fact this cartoon says we'd
like to roll over this CD what's your
new rate the banker says you'll owe us
one and a half percent a year not too
far from where we are today so that was
when I was sixty ten years later
stock market is today at fifteen eight
when I these are the stock market levels
my various ages cycles I've seen Bank
and remember the SNL industry has
disappeared farmland prices gone up gone
down gold housing inflation interest
rates oil prices stock market tax reform
all these things can lend you to say no
trends going to last forever even though
we would hope that it would but
historically they don't the chinese say
it this way forecasting is difficult
especially about the future and wayne
gretzky when asked how he was why he was
such a good hockey player he says i
never skate to where the puck is but to
where the puck is going to be and that's
the reason that we're focused on the
economy is we'd like to know where the
pucks going to be two years three years
five years ten years when I retire
whatever it may be well what's the
conclusion I'm bad luck if you look at
you just want to stay away from me on
every decade now here's the conclusion
economic uncertainty is certain and
economic prosperity is certain only in
retrospect now we know that
experientially but do we know that in
terms of our decision-making because
that all your perspective driving the
way you think is going to drive your
behavior and economic cycles our
normative and the future cannot be
predicted because you don't know what
you don't know I mean sure an Ulster
that in 1996 in 1990 it was announced
that Atlanta was getting the 1996
Olympics and so in Atlanta we began
hearing stories about the the crowds the
the traffic what it was going to be like
and the conclusion was it was a drumbeat
don't even think about going to the
airport during the Olympics don't even
think about getting on the road even at
2 o'clock in the morning there's going
to be gridlock you just need to take
those three weeks and either leave
Atlanta or hunker down in your house
because you're not going to be able to
move the Olympics opened up and the
traffic disappeared it was the best
three weeks from a traffic standpoint
Atlanta has ever experienced no weights
on the MARTA no weights at the airport
why well people aren't stupid they'll
always make decisions in their
self-interest so I was running a
business or what did we do well we said
take your vacation during that time we
made provisions for people to work at
home if they wanted to everybody in
Atlanta made provisions for this
gridlock that was going to occur
therefore it didn't occur you don't know
what you don't know it's the same thing
with y2k you remember the fear around
y2k I was on a radio program with dr.
Dobson and some others who had written
on y2k and I was the only guy in the
room that said I don't know where that's
really going to happen or not and the
reason was because I had experienced the
Atlanta Olympics I thought you know as a
businessman I'm not stupid
I'm not going to just let it happen to
me what do I need to do so you can't
control individual behavior I do know
that that's an important thing for
economists to understand because people
will always operate in their
self-interest and I've watched that with
the people that I've worked with but
applying biblical wisdom in financial
decision-making results in three things
and this is
almost a summary statement perspective
and Hebrews 13:5 says be content with
what you have for I have said I'll never
leave you nor forsake you that leads to
contentment that's why I wanted the
perspective the paradox of prosperity
the economic uncertainty there are other
perspectives biblical perspectives that
are important but the the thing leading
to contentment is the belief in Hebrews
13:5 and you know what the the answer to
the question how much is enough is I
told you that's a question it says in
there be content with what you have so
how much is enough what you have that's
the beginning point if you're not
content with what you have you'll never
be content with what you don't have
now that's simple there's nothing
complex about that it's biblical
and as as Business School professors and
economics professors keep bringing your
students the right perspective beginning
with biblical perspective on the economy
and also on financial decision making is
really important because you would like
your students to leave having an impact
on the world but also having an impact
in their own lives by experiencing
contentment when I look back at the
clients that I worked with at Ronald
bloom company contentment was one of
those things that characterized them
because they had an eternal perspective
on wealth they understood what role
money played in their lives secondly our
principles so if I have biblical wisdom
in my decision-making I'm going to
follow biblical principles 2nd Timothy
3:16 you all know that scripture God's
all scriptures in God breathed and is
profitable for teaching instruction
correction etc etc is that true
absolutely it's true there's twenty
three hundred and fifty verses in the
Bible dealing with money and money
management you can take the Bible and
develop a biblical financial approach
the way you think in the way you act and
the way you process what you know God's
Word works
it just works and I want to tell you
what Wall Street is only interested in
what works that's what they're they're
interested in selling advice and
products and in Wall Street listens to
the financial advisor because they're
trying to deliver to the financial
advisor products and services the
adviser is listening to his client they
want to deliver what the client wants so
here's the vision if we can change Main
Street will change Wall Street
I absolutely seriously we can do it and
if you change Main Street you'll change
the world I'm sorry if you change Wall
Street you'll change the world I was
testifying before Congressional
subcommittee in the early 90s Senator
Dodd we talked about the dodd-frank act
and Senator Dodd was doing the
questioning and he said what would you
tell the American family about finances
and ice I thought when I tell him what
I'm going to tell him he's going to
laugh but I said senator I would tell
the American family spend less in urine
to avoid the use of debt three build
liquidity or flexibility or margin into
your financial situation and four set
long-term goals so that you can
prioritize your spending between the
short term and the long term I thought
he would laugh but he picked up his
pencil wrote him down and repeated him
back to me and then he said you know it
seems to me that that work at any income
level
and I said God gave me some wisdom and I
said you're right sender including
United States government and that's true
those are the those are four fundamental
biblical principles of money and money
management and if I would add two more
which I didn't share at that time would
be number five would be give generously
and lastly would be to understand that
God owns at all those six principles
decision-making principles can change
everything about your finances and
they're not God didn't make it hard he
made it really easy so if I can build my
life on financial principles out of
scripture that will lead to confidence
and decision making here's the
characteristics of biblical wisdom it's
always right it's always relevant and
it's never going to change
now I was with a South African person a
number of months ago and he was telling
me about how he would go from South
Africa to North Africa to smuggle Bibles
into the community Muslim world and the
thing dawned on me so here we are I'm an
American he's the South Africa and he's
going to North Africa smuggling Bibles
and you know what that Bible that he
smuggled into the Muslim world is the
same one I have on my desk
does that not help our communication if
we're all talking out of the same
playbook you bet that's why we can
change the way people think about money
and the way they communicate about money
in fact the third thing
well you've read Matthew 7:24 house
built on sand house built on rock this
is a picture of right after Hurricane
Ike on Galveston Island in Houston or in
Texas and it says the Bible says the
winds came the rivers rose and I think
the and the rain beat down well that's a
picture of a hurricane and here's the
results of a hurricane that's a house
this is another picture that same house
that is a picture of Matthew 7:24 227
now the story behind that house is those
people that gone through a hurricane
before and they built a hurricane proof
house as a consequence when the
hurricane came they were prepared that's
having the right perspective is making
the right decisions and my point is this
if we can bring biblical thinking into
the business students mind we will have
created something that will change the
way this world operates it starts at the
lowest level the individual decision
maker
I believe let me close with this one of
the things the third thing that I have
found is that people if they have
conceptualization they have a basis of
communication and as a businessman when
I could conceptualize things I'm they
were transferable and replicable so I
gave you six principles and I'm gonna
tell you this there's only five things
you can do with money and these are the
five you can give it away you can pay
your taxes you can invest it or save it
you can pay off your debt and you will
and what's left is your living expenses
everything else goes into the living
expense bucket God's Word speaks to
every one of those buckets well that's
not hard is it I've had advisers tell me
I take the five uses of money into every
client meeting because this is
everything we decide is going to have an
impact on those five buckets everything
we talk about finances it's going to
have an impact well why do you invest
and save in order to meet long-term term
goals and there's only six long-term
goals my retirement my family needs like
college education or whatever maximize
my giving the lifestyle desires I have
start a business or retire all debt if I
have the right perspective and if I'm
following biblical principles and
decision making and I have everything
conceptualized so that I can talk to my
wife about it then I've got the tools to
be successful as a financial
steward in how I make and how I manage
money here's what I'm trying to do I'm
going to close with this I think that my
desire nightwear God's got me right now
he is thinking about can we create a an
industry if you will a subset of the
financial services world where we have
biblical financial counselors everyplace
and that the world recognizes in other
words could we recreate the Christian
counseling world but it's the financial
services world Christian counseling and
financial counseling are very similar
and right now
we don't have a subset that's recognized
Ameriprise who has 12,000 advisers had
me up there twice in the last two years
and they asked the question is the
evangelical market big and two are their
needs different than the rest of the
world because we market to entrepreneurs
we market to women and we market to
libous lesbians and gays because their
planning needs are different we sent
them a white paper they bought into it
and they said they are now training
there we're training their advisors to
integrate biblical wisdom into their
advice and counsel we're going to visit
Morgan Stanley yet this year I've just
got an email last week from Wells Fargo
Advisors God's doing something out there
and you all are a huge part of that
because if we're going to create
something that has influence it's got to
have professional credibility in around
me as we've already got professional
credibility we've been at it for 40
years we've got 1,500 advisors at
kingdom' advisors 350 at staff around a
balloon coming we've proven that
biblical wisdom works but we do not have
academic credibility and so we're doing
is moving all of our training into
universities obviously we're starting
with Indiana Wesleyan because they've
asked for it I met with the Dean of the
business school at Liberty University a
couple days ago they want to integrate
biblical wisdom into their financial
planning curriculum that's where we're
headed we've got to we've got for you
people to be teaching God's wisdom when
it comes to
and money management and then we need
theological credibility which is really
pastors and seminaries buying into this
I think I'll stop at that point I'm not
done talking but I'll stop because I
want to give time I think we've got
about ten minutes left and what I'd like
to do is that right Anita ten minutes
okay if we're going to if anybody wants
to answer some some questions I just
know that my kids said dad you may not
understand it but you can explain it so
ask me anything sir will you tell the
story about the founding of the fun okay
I was speaking on a cruise ship I feel
called to speak on cruise ships and and
one of the people there heard my heard
my talk and the title of the talk was
how much is enough and he was agitated
and he said luck he said I've got a
business worth 30 million that's way
more than I'll ever need the rest of my
life I'm gonna go home sell my business
okay what you gonna do then he said I'm
gonna go to work for a full-time
ministry I knew enough about this guy
that I knew he could screw up a lot of
ministries he was a he was an
entrepreneur in the truest sense I began
meeting with this couple and this was in
the 80s and his business was demolition
he had big equipment and obviously if
you're going to build a demolition
business you got a lot of heavy
equipment the conventional way to do
that as you fund it through debt which
he had done and I after listened to him
I said you know I said you got the gift
of making money why don't you take that
money and do something totally
counterintuitive and that's pay off all
your debt
I was totally stupid from as a fine if I
were a finance professor to do that but
he those six principles he wanted to
apply him so he paid off all of his debt
well 1990-91 California went into a
tremendous recession if you remember and
every one of his competitors went out of
business and he had a lot of cash he
bought bought everybody out he was the
only one that did demolition work west
of the Rockies I was in his home the
night
watching the World Series when the San
Francisco earthquake happened you know
it was his equipment that showed up to
begin taking down what needed to be
taken down a few years later there was a
North quake in Los Angeles and I said
you know God descends an earthquake
anytime he needs more money well he
ended up selling his business 460
million he put a hundred million into
ncf when ncf had one part-time employee
and said you can keep all the earnings
off of that money to fund the growth of
ncf the and incidentally he and his wife
had set a goal to give away a billion
dollars in their life so that funded ncf
it got it started and allowed them to
grow that business and today as Jay
mentioned they've given away five
billion dollars since that time we're
getting close to being able to give away
a billion a year so that's the story he
was obedient he was totally
counterintuitive but he was following
biblical wisdom and God took it and did
something beyond all he could think ask
or even imagine according to Ephesians
3:20 so thanks for asking a question yes
mr. blue our young people are walking
out of our schools with tremendous debt
and to a certain extent if one of the
advice is to go into the major
corporation and influence the major
corporation in about five years you need
to get an MBA from a very good school
and take out more debt now you walk on
five years later you hit another wall
where's your recommendation to those
individuals now they have the MBA and a
great deal of debt for their next step
and how does the debt that the young
people are walking out with impacting
their use of your model well the model
works and the first question would be
that I would ask a student is gonna
borrow the money how you gonna pay it
back and put it in your plan buy at a
seminary student one time who called in
a radio : program and he said God had
called him to the mission field and he
was going to borrow money to go to
seminary and I said did God call you to
the mission field he said sure I said
well then how you going to pay back
student debt and he said well I don't
know I guess
I'll have to work after I got out of
seminary and I did something really wild
and reckless I said well I mean let me
give you some advice or suggestion said
why don't you go to school if you got
enough money for a week stay a week got
enough money to stay for two week stay
for two weeks and see what God does long
story short I got a letter from him
several years later he went through the
litany of how God had provided for him
you know dorm counselor and waiting
tables and all of this he was able to
graduate from seminary with no debt and
then go on to the mission field
now that's impractical and but it was
built around the fact that he had a
calling so my question would be how you
going to pay it back just take them five
uses of money put it down there and see
how you're going to pay it back I think
then it will be self revelatory and
people will think differently about it
perhaps they'll take another approach to
it because I don't think you necessarily
have to go the conventional way which is
student debt that's not a specific
answer and I wouldn't give a specific
answer on that I would give a
principles-based answer and that was if
you believe what God's Word says then
follow the principles it's not wrong to
borrow money nothing in the Bible says
it's wrong to borrow money it's wrong to
not repay money that you borrow and
borrowing money
well again the scripture doesn't say
that it's wrong but it could be stupid
and I don't mean that about student debt
because I would ask the question if I'm
going into debt is the economic return
greater than the economic cost first
secondly do I have a peace of mind and
heart about going in to this money or
borrowing this money thirdly I would say
if I'm married or going to be married
does my spouse or future spouse share my
goals and values and is going to buy
into my debt or am I going to buy into
their debt so just if you don't ask the
right question you never get the right
answer so I would approach students with
the questions how you gonna pay it back
does it make economic sense does your
family be at a married family or parents
or whatever agree with you on this it
may drive decision making a different
way and again I am NOT saying don't
borrow there's cases where borrow
student debt would be one where you
could say the economic return is greater
than the economic cost now I wouldn't
say that about an Ivy League education
quite frankly I wouldn't say that about
a lot of private school education
you know I sent my kids to my kids to
Wake Forest and we paid 12/5 a year all
in today at sixty thousand I'm not sure
his Wake Forest worth a quarter of a
million dollars after tax just asking
the question but thanks for the question
yes I have a question about the affluent
society we live in and the accumulation
of wealth and has to do with giving and
you see if you could strike a balance
between regular ongoing weekly monthly
giving as opposed to someone who has
Kingdom values who are who say money
aside for a larger gift can help me
strike a balance between those two
immediate versus long-term giving you
bet I can
and if you look at the chart the giving
up on the top left is the short-term
giving that's I would call it income
statement giving obedience giving
tithing is where that fits but if you
notice at the bottom right or I'm sorry
bottom left there maximize giving some
people said long-term giving goals like
this person how do you balance you only
got so many buckets and so much money
and it's always going to be an
individual situation the bottom really
represents balance sheet giving the top
represents income statement giving the
bottom represents balance sheet giving
and the older you get like today if I
put that chart up for me I've only got
three buckets that's to give pain my
taxes and my living expenses because
we've reached at age 71 we're
financially independent kids are all
taken care of
so I don't have that but it's taken me
270 to get there but I've always been
working that way three levels of giving
I think it's in maybe Simpson said this
amount you should give which is the I
think income statement giving could give
which is balance sheet giving in other
words it's there all I have to do is
make a decision to give and the third
level is faith giving would give and
that's something you can't see but it
says it's like this bucket down there
I'm gonna maximize my giving and that is
God I'm gonna give currently I'm going
to give on my balance sheet and here's
my finish line and anything I get above
that finish line is going to be given so
there's three levels of giving you can
put it all on the chart and begin to
work it out all biblical prints all
principles are worked out on a unique
and individual basis we've got somebody
down here got one over here okay go
ahead that's fine we'll get that and
we'll quit after these two mr. blue a
question about your comment that you'd
work with Indiana Wesleyan only if you'd
be able to partner with Christian
colleges and and kind of get out the
resources and materials just what what
what should the rest of us anticipate
with that over the next year or coming
years will there be multimedia videos
will there be powerpoints will there be
slides what what you know what what is
there to look forward to I'd like to
turn around say what do you need okay if
you tell me what you need we've got tons
and tons of content both from me and
from others that have been in this
biblical world so if you come back and
say you know this would be really
helpful one of the things we're working
on right now is a biblically based
personal finance textbook because
there's really nothing available
anyplace that starts with the biblical
wisdom and works it out practically the
second thing is we're building that
master's program and we're moving
professional training into universities
which I'd love for you all to pick up a
professional training and and recruit
these potential CFPs there's a job
market it's one of the fastest growing
job markets there is and there's no
supply chain supply line so tell me what
you need tell us what you need and we've
probably got it we just need to do it
it's really a high priority to move it
into as many universities is what we can
because then
with that academic credibility you know
maybe there's research projects that you
can do as an individual University in
this particularly we've got a lot of
research projects but limited
opportunity to to do them so if you've
got an interest in this area and you
want to do a research project we'd love
to to partner with you on research and
then publish it so thanks for the
question one last one
I guess what did we have oh okay
last question where to give or how to
decide where you'd give yeah when I've
looked at this in a macro basis god we
always give to where we share a vision
and where we have a relationship you
know people come to when they come to
Atlanta every Development Officer that
comes to Atlanta wants to get together
with me because I know a lot of rich
people and it's true I know a lot of
rich people but I say to them look if
they don't share the vision with you and
if you don't have a relationship with
you they're not going to give to your
whatever it may be regardless of the
passion that you have so I believe that
God gives us uniquely the the places
where we should give and it's where you
share the vision where you share the
heart and where you have a relationship
which is why I think first giving should
always be to the church it's my humble
but accurate opinion
I'll quit with that thank you very much